[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mic Check Lois Mic Check make sure you
hear me make sure you I can hear
everybody yes sir yes sir you know down
the old mats we'll let the chat know let
us know if y'all can hear us shout
anything but you got mad jokes on our
stream fan I seem going in I need to let
you you need to let us know if you hear
us right now before we go loud everyone
good come on I will receive this I just
want to chat the a big Keith Thank You
Big Chief the old man too good no doubt
we'd better go alive in the field
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right hopefully people could hear us
and we can get this thing going oh my
god we are laughs again happy Easter
Sunday and welcome to the iron Lords
podcast and the Lords of gaming dotnet
episode number 153 bad bit can hear us I
feel good and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day I'm extremely excited
about our special guests and we've got
Final Fantasy 7 remake playstation 5
dual sense
cyberpunk next-generation excuse and
inside Xbox to discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce the
Lord who is not only a true friend to
the realm from the very beginning but
his high quality videos balanced
opinions and passion for gaming Plus
combat sports make him a perfect fit for
the roundtable of the Lords introducing
the creating host of the grounded game
of YouTube channel and panelists of the
RDX podcast fellow 49er fans fellow
combat sports fan and the Lord of the
smoothest voice combined with the most
hilarious skits you will ever see on
YouTube live from the Bay Area and
making his return into the realm of the
Lord's my man lured Jade Fonzarelli aka
the grounded gamer how you doing sir
hey man it's good to be here thank you
for the oh well you had to bring up the
49ers yes we can't do all this event if
you if you would've said this season we
thought we would have had prior and say
you'll go to the Superbowl bro like Cabo
it was it was a bitter end but such a
magical ride no the Cresta right quick
we got squirrely Dan in there man so you
got to read that work for a de gotta
read that what I read
so we got a - we got a $2.00 super chair
from scarlet donation for the internet
bill I appreciate it man so we go help
adequately a multi-billion dollar
corporation can't keep this stuff
together
in all fairness you know I'm sure that
the traffic going on is probably
quadruple what it's been in the past
three or four years yeah Madigan his
area had outage so it was it was
definitely nice fall so don't come for
my man John Campinas London Street was
bootlegging stuff on the PDF did he
killing us he said Shanahan got what he
deserved oh you know I've been playing
that Final Fantasy 7 remake that go yeah
I mean we're I'm sure we're gonna get
into that hold yes the Final Fantasy
talking when we do I've got some great
things to say about it but I've also got
some coming for the go is cool cool hey
you ready nope
we got the Four Horsemen of baby here at
the round table
the original Lords at around I'm
co-hosting almost my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of reviews and the half
of the young wolf my man Lord addict I
know sir I'm doing fine tired rotated in
the past three days I have probably
gotten like five hours of sleep yeah and
the funny thing I tried my hardest to
beat this game before I LP but I only
got up to chapter 18 and that is as far
as I could get only that's a blaze bro
yeah that's what I haven't even played
it at home like my boss have called me
she's like such-and-such he called him
would you mind taking honestly look I
was thinking myself I could play this
here at home I mean it doesn't really
matter
it could go in 35 hours in mmm so get
you riled up get you ready cake cheese
no you're good are you all ready don't
we got almost a to-go gaming Lord the
solo Weber who lives with a single
player selfish experience and also the
sastra Thomas mr. offline plural profile
Illuminati and the person who reads the
patreon better than me every week mommy
Lois solve how we do exactly like the
chili clown what's your voice they like
it but it's bad they don't like me the
good stuff helped me out through this
recovery and thank you course to lady
solve taking care of me
despite my best efforts to keep her away
from me she's like shut up it was the
social distancing thank you very much
what you've been playing sir
I haven't played Final Fantasy holidays
we go do to go avoid you bear what it a
word that goes a the barbecue every time
we mention Red Dead - you put up the
goat emoji
that's it now you go to vote go to
foster put that final fantasy seven
brunette and doom and doom is kicking my
let me go ahead and state right now
shout out to Eddie faster that's right I
actually donated it to the aisle piece
Oh got it
I'm on like like I want Mars I'm
toad-like that's close to the end of the
game mmm like I love it
tell him y'all hit his due
he said he put 35 I was in final friends
yes you going to step away from me video
that's why the inning Wow that's my
attic care host that's why I used he's
the perfect man like I tried I tried my
hardest to be do maternal before final
fantasy camera because I knew once he
came out I was gonna be like what to do
but I did three missions left but I was
like I can't do the fact that you got
that far is ridiculous he got any
internet left I did I did it's probably
the best first-person shooter I've ever
play no doubt no doubt
so what else off just bit its banette
that's pretty much it that's pretty much
like I said last we got finished a Jedi
Falls notice I went back in there just
to clean up a couple of achievements and
stuff like that okay on that that's it
no doubt and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
mmm the lord of combat sports king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than their premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert move it ooh
beloved loïc a guy you do exert Oh
extremely tired got in the day and I
said you know what you know I'm gonna do
first of all ain't no turn the beat
around on that Wow you know he is a big
boy so I want you guys to stop going
looking at the promo video thinking you
sort of video go watch the video either
loads of game and dotnet and all go to
the YouTube channel and watch KO west on
iron Lords podcast oh that way you can
see the whole video and stop thinking
you saw something yeah you know I like
doing with the helmet I see your scoop
of behind it yeah
or video you know what's going on you
know one last come out like that but you
know exactly who I'm talking to
anyway um so you can put up that game
pass emoji Oh Janey pass was in his game
bag this week we thought what we doing
this week without the field ominous
Maximus misses his field jumping game is
funny listen I got journey to the savage
planet you know it was it was what I
thought stupid game was a stupid game
that was trying to be I got it though to
Cresto stop the stitch to dial super
chat when are we addressing this
fisher-price concern oh the crest or the
crest up millions knowing I don't know
oh yeah my bad my bad Millie's bears
want to get in there I don't know why I
want to get in there
thank you for that Holmes finney-smith
man was me who gots me spent collected
that's please me for sure he always
watches every video sniff the book of X
could take this game yo is so much fun
it is absolutely amazing it's so
colorful the world is so bright even on
the regular s and even on the X it's a
beautiful game I love the exploration I
love the walking back to the full motion
video stuff and like it's stuff that you
do and they have like little
infomercials and little stuff they
create a nice little world for you to
get lost in and it's it feels light and
fun but malicious in the same manner
it's like it's catering today kidding
you and also that you know that moon
spirit is of you guys you get to do a
whole lot of mixing and matching with
stuff it's a really good game if you
want to check that out also I'm playing
on Momo Dora is so nice this is game
pass to yes yes sir you yeah no nothing
but game pass um sorry that's where I'm
at with it
because that's where my fame finances is
I think everybody should be gamepads and
utilizing it to the best of their
ability also I wanted to address one
thing but we got I don't here you go
with their same energy because
everybody's talking all that crap oh the
PlayStation the pro is be in the X or
the moon the patch came and it's the
patch then put the game
head and shoulders above the inferior
version and I just really wanted to
address that because nobody is in my
timeline I wanna know where you Sony
heads that we have generals that we're
bosses that there's nobody showing up in
my time I'm gonna beat ya'll down so bad
you know a king when it comes down to
that situation a lot of these guys out
there don't understand and they said
they'll never understand that better
hardware will always be superior
understand that no matter what they just
go along with these false narratives all
the time talking about how my game runs
better on the pro it comes down to
optimization they don't care they don't
want to hear it they won't know you you
ain't a developer you keep all the good
early consumer and if my product ain't
as good as that other product or
inferior hardware as well don't spread
that realness into rum and IOP not
saying what you want to hear but what
you need to hear so say I said yeah but
some shots [ __ ] yeah yeah for me what
has been man I mean Oh first was
shout-out to the last word podcast my
brother he boxes best destiny podcast
you have not heard we were talking it up
man some good discussions yeah just ease
in a spooky place we're not happy we're
not happy but we had to say some things
you got to get at some people you know
me yeah that was a good last word
listen we got to keep it true even let's
switch you know someone she loved you
got to go in but oh shout out yo fozzy
gonna be proud of you miss I am a new
foogoo owner stadia gang let's go free
tidy nice pods let's do it baby
I'm wish you could have pulled me into
your arms of the last word because we're
talking all that Sadie it is to stay D
etre tell them how see you if y'all
didn't watch the last word yo I can't
find a match the population I give
myself and I do myself to flirt alert
because I tried to play a batch here I
could not play a PvP match for two hours
back then I wasn't that bad I think well
I could even get into that to tell you
if it was leg at a PvP on a PV II it was
I know my connection like that answer it
wasn't that bad no Xiaomei for tell you
new gang stadia stand up free daddy
listen y'all 399 you get a little muddy
fling this what you doing you get it big
free everyone that got that jump in the
bushes and you know stay there have a
little cook have a little picnic did you
see on a page it's free and people are
complaining
listen free daddy now all you do is you
jump up in there you sign up you
download you get all leggings then you
can sir this description of
nothing gets charged you good for like
two loves I'm in there man fool gag
let's do it
so I was doing nad then I do a lot of
remote streaming I'm saying I was that
Laura card needle saying that you know
it kind of reminds me of Laura Kane was
that when when he bought halo wars - and
never touched it out you were supposed
to drag me through you were supposed to
finish that for me so we could do the
coop what happened we're gonna stream
that game you gotta help me all right
Savva get throw straight up Smitty Smith
fire on a super chat shout to Lords of
gaming dotnet iron Lords and Lord Fonz
hashtag plastic Ward's see we got the
new law emoji you see the new Fire Lord
crispy right now we get the super chance
that's a better ILP but you ever doing
that a lot of console stream and I've
been doing on phantom doctrine from Xbox
to my PC still works fantastic I love
how it's one to one as far as that is
going and then um obviously I tested a
Playstation out what they would there
was a remote play to PC as well but yo
brought out old-school wipeout remember
wipeouts off oh I forgot how much I
loved that game the old Mega Collection
4k HDR don't Club beats the bang is yo
wipeout well it has the Vita versions
all all the ridges yeah man it's really
good so again pick that up and rockin
that of course I know the goal is going
down we'll talk about that
a lot of stuff to talk about but now we
got to what the Lord's have been playing
and lore files has received the
treatment multiple times out to the cars
driving by right now um he was here ILP
their eighty five and forty seven so uh
Fonz man I gotta ask you real quick um
top five revisited we have for you Red
Dead Redemption number one Last of Us
number two halo combat Evolved number
three the go Final Fantasy seven number
four and Mass Effect 2 number five is
that remaining intact or do we need to
change things oh oh turn it back up a
little bit for you talk a little bit to
feel longer so basically the Red Dead
series both games are together okay oh
it's the other cuz they go we talked
about the list and the mission we're
talking about my list not yours my
beloved my beloved Final Fantasy seven
is getting pushed down one now no it's
getting kicked to the curb just a little
bit just down so we're going down to
number five that's going down to number
six
Oh strapped off so that's the one that's
removed for to read dad's know it's it's
it's removed for a game that I put that
I fully played through and just fell in
love with just this last year which one
and that was the witcher 3 is it's one
of the goats man no doubt it's one of
the best ever i the dlc to that game
really changed for me the fact that
every piece that they came out with to
that game was gold in him I'm telling
you saying
so what's lobby project Red's got it
what's la that's that's gonna be that's
gonna be in my number four slot okay so
which time update it on a flower
yeah Witcher 3 okay number four okay
well yeah so the metal Mass Effect goes
down to five yes
- affect you goes down to five I love
that Mass Effect yeah so a salvation
baby I couldn't get I couldn't get rid
of Mass Effect Final Fantasy seven just
one notch its top 10 euro Russia good
horrible combat they'll like that which
they I like the coveted which they don't
like Mass Effect I guess he could get
behind that Alessi to do that but some
QW vampire what's going on brother no
doubt so and then the new question which
you have missed we just debuted this
shout-out to Lord boo who helped us out
with this this is a tough one I think
all generations favoring console of all
time
and why yeah yeah you're the spot now
you like us there's so many systems I
love everyone except for the Neo Geo
I've never owned that because that was
just to explain only K hat now he's the
only person in Hood yeah Kings the only
one that had that I think is at the end
of the day the one that always comes to
mind because I just I loved it so much
everything from its form factor to its
accessories all the games Oh Dreamcast
solo Dreamcast was just such a great
console I'm sorry to me say I just had
so many good consoles that just failed
unfortunately no shout-out to Sega CD
though because that one was trashed
which we do [ __ ] and Sega CD hey cuz I'm
like this is a glorified Genesis with
music and I'm thinking armonica these
games is gonna be looking better no all
I got was bitter Sam let us out I was
like now I wasn't for can't try to get
me all that hustle 2k Gasol trying to
get me with that I said you know
that's a shark night trap that would be
doing it for me power power when you put
that together with the 32x on the final
fight CD you know I like Samurai Shodown
on the 3do that I had classic she filed
idea was kind of tall yeah I think we
got to unscrew your joy just to get the
d-pad loose so you can get the hate
button direction of thing mr. Hoffa give
me your controller yes I true
quarterback the next day and my street
fighter was throwing a Dickens all night
shout out the Vista yeah the Dreamcast
were those VM use remember yes yeah and
I mean you could choose your plane yes
mad it was great for that because the
woof was great yeah cuz they could see
your screen you could use you know via
how did they lose him out in a middle
period right before Pete everybody was
anticipating PS - yes - Kay it was like
that was it it was online online first
thing yeah VM use an amazing launch low
what are the best launch lineups a lot
of people may not know this but shout
out to Microsoft they're the ones that
put that online yeah yes they have
window-seat amazing master a salute to
Sega true arcade perfection out fires
out that will help scream in the
building sound too squirrely Dan
he said oMG cast controller blew up and
almost electrocuted his friend back in
the day solution
shout out the mojo blues good to see you
brother he said it lost because of no
DVD player yeah that DVD was a big deal
he's got a lot of cats and a hoodie and
ODB bu-bye yes
they had a gangster disciple really was
that's a good system choice so let's do
the poll last week poll results are any
of the people who have spoken to the
question with the games industry gearing
up for more software than with delays
like the Last of Us 2 etc due to the
virus pandemic how do you feel Microsoft
should handle halo infinites launched
alongside Series X if only the physical
release is not 100% ready and the winner
of these Ray's a closed four-way il
peephole is halo infinite 2 important
for Series X launch launch digital first
Wow coming a second very close to 46% at
43% was the completely delay halo
infinite until the entire game is ready
group then coming in at third place at
8% only percent was the launched a
campaign physical released and
multiplayer later and last place only 1%
of the vote I don't care unless grounded
or battle told launched before halo
infinite is very in the poll Lord addict
this was a big discussion for me in you
offline what do you feel that people
want if it's ready to go did you - I
think this is what you wanted right yeah
I feel like if it comes between that and
not launching with the Xbox series X I
feel like that is the better move for
them in general because they're gonna
you know we know every box with the
series X is gonna have anywhere from
lots of 3 months of game pass you got a
download that anyway
so that's true that's true it is you you
were - what about to my attention that
even with gears right they had like the
gate pass ultimate guys got it like a
week early digital-only so they've been
already kind of in that bag with
launching the digital release first so
I'll be interested I know Phil has some
comments on that attend that the hard
way is coming regardless but he's gonna
give the team time so we shall see but
we all get into these topics and
oh we have something to give away oh I'm
bugging solve see see that's why you
back it see the bank always put me in
check that let's go before we got some
giveaways we got some big some girls to
give out thanks to give out hold on
let's go
as you guys know we've had a Final
Fantasy 7 remake gleam IO contest going
on yeah
of course you weren't able to end it
before the launch of the game just cuz
we started a little bit late but here we
are
launch week of the game and we have
ourselves a winner so before I get into
that thank you to everyone who
participated
all of you who did shy see things to
participate shame on you and as always
much love to Lord Ptak
now though the king of the banhammer and
catch a ball you frauds out there trying
to win with your legal means of winning
every time we do one of these the man
goes through absolute hell to sort of
weed out the bad seeds and come up with
legitimate people yes now though and our
winner of the Final Fantasy 7 remake
[Laughter]
Greg the thing about it is again shout
out congratulations Lord boss moves but
we had a considerable amount of people
trying together like a considerable
amount of people a lot of frauds
so it got weeded down to two I mean and
rightfully so the people that are always
there with us following us so I'm glad
that somebody you always there with us
gets this so lord boss moves mmm I will
hit you up with that cold oh you let me
know what you want what you want to
happen but I either way I'll get at you
in the dance no duh slow boss moves with
everybody participate and don't fret
lords we will have another giveaway tone
right back we're gonna do one this week
so
hopefully uptick PD and then we got
something cooking for y'all so you get
right back in the winning circle so that
all we got solver we good banks Quinn
all right let's get into these topics
man topic one let's get the flames going
on topic 1
Lord addict man stop let's let's pull
the fan boy out add a quick quick let's
be real here I've waited for this game
for a long time I was real nervous when
it when I started playing this you know
I actually I gotta be honest man let's
get it ought to be honest yes
what Square Enix is done here is the
most amazing for the most part I first
off I have the thing I have to say is
this is definitely worth the $60 ok
cloudy in the back at the end of the day
I would prefer you know I'm not gonna go
too much of the detail I want to hear
your guys is first and then I'll give my
detailed perspective but you know the
first thing I want to say is if they
make all of them like they've made this
one okay they have five their expansion
that you won't be a million dollars for
this pocket watch it okay universe the
universe that I grew up there not just
doing you know I want to go and say that
this game breed defines the way remakes
are made your snitch said you said you
guys just sit that bad back 250 Bri was
good oh so we talking that goes the game
is phenomenal it's like right now it's
my game of the year by far bro yo and
love bad across so on decide I'm gonna
let that out
ah come on you you are saying hold on to
it man and for the people that you know
I understand you know your concert you
thought process you know that this is
one fifth of the game but all I'm saying
is I'd rather this and then just give me
a $60.00 exactly what I've learned in
1990 fair this is actually there's new
characters there's new areas new stuff
that they put in the game that wasn't in
the original they've changed the story
they've changed you know the the
perspective of people it's it's not the
same game by any means by any means at
all yes it's it's we don't isn't it
there is more new stuff in this game
than old stuff okay fair enough your
list let's get the guest in man we got
we got a lot of funds really in the
building you know I'm saying so what
fast man I know you picked it up we've
been talking you know I mean but just
overall your experience first of all
where you are how far are you at the
game right now I'm about halfway through
I think there's 18 levels and again I'm
at nine right now okay okay
so about how much game play hours you
think you've put it up to nine Oh at
least I say about almost close to 20 Wow
and and and that's because I want to
tell you a little bit about some of the
bad that you know oh there's there's
there's so there's so many tedious
little small like side missions that are
just and I know they're side missions
but I like to do everything in an RPG
okay like I like to buff up my
characters before I go and meet the man
you know and so I'm sitting there doing
these missions and I'm like chasing kids
around finding say what was teacher who
didn't appreciate the cat was foot
what's funny funds you guys Cognito I
was like yeah man I was doing the side
quest so they started having me chase
down kids and chase down a path I was
like now I'm done with this I don't
think this is where addict does
everything any today if this again
addicts gonna do it no it's
I am NOT looking for little kids and
look wait so wait do I do the sockless
no no I did I did probably 80% of them
but I'm not looking for cats I think
that's why I think that's why we're
gonna be differ on the whole phenomenal
thing because I've done literally
everything you could do so far look at
the little quest thing menu cause if you
go to the mad compress rr1 like you can
see all the things know you know they
open up more like more side quests come
up when you do all those side quests
yeah well more come up and they're just
that didn't happen for me all 13 I
didn't only do like three or four cuz
I'm not that questing I'm not someone's
errands but the thing is is like I feel
like and this is the thing like when I
first started up the game just to put
some good out there cuz I don't you guys
know I do love it because when I first
fired it up and I had so many nostalgic
feels I had some chills though in that
music music Vaughn's was good and then
as soon as the first battle when you're
standing there and and and I think the
first time you were standing there with
Tifa and that music he is I was like oh
my god this is like taking me back right
yes um lots of feels great battles the
combat comments all about that comment
combat the comment is great the combat
is that combination of live you know
action with with that you know was the
spells you can kind of pause for a
little bit you the spell do that sort of
stuff it works incredibly well but again
I'm flowing through the story and it's
all great
right I'm going through you know the you
know the whole beginning portion when
you're going through the the building
and everything you're setting off bombs
ball you know doing all that and they
feel so good and then you go to the
slums and you're like man I feel it I'm
in the slum like this is like that's
hideous work you got to do
for all these people that's right and
that's where it dragged down for me and
that's what he got to the slums way
dragged for you yeah and then and then I
got past the two slum areas I'm in the
market area and now I'm still seems like
I'm still doing more tedious working
like when do we get back to the story in
just like we do we do got to be fair
they don't expect you to do all the side
quests if you don't want to finish you
make it seem like it have to do it yeah
you only have to do one or two before it
opens up like what realistic in a game
like this I feel like in a game like
this but that's just your style of
gameplay that's not have stuff you know
and and so no Russian says in the chat
he said so I'm about a frying-pan
mission to fetch my friend and yeah that
was one mission both of those side
missions are awesome in November well
give you the side missions in final
fantasy that they're bad you can really
have good rewards let me ask that's
that's that's the extent of my you know
the music everything yeah yeah yeah oh
and in the main story watch what you go
through there is great what everything
the attic said about all the characters
all the different missions and stuff
that they've added are fantastic in that
regard right but I feel like they added
all these slum missions and to kind of
bolster up that the hours you play in
the game all right let me ask you this
before I give it to saga I hear where
you're going with it my question is
though isn't in the original Final
Fantasy that section you may have been
in there a total of like 10 and 15
minutes and then they give you in a
whole open world section yeah of this
town net and and then development
character available people who were so
inconsequential if you don't say it said
now they like fully fleshed out can
appreciate yeah I appreciate it but the
thing is like I don't appreciate getting
to know these little kids and there
is that God did you do that did you do
the quest with the teacher and the kids
yeah finish that okay dude did you meet
that teacher again later on in the
market yes like I said like you know
when it comes to particularly let's take
the secondary when you came in you do
the sectarian literally in the original
game Barret hires you for a second job
gives you money and you'll eat then
literally you're there for 15 minutes
right but you know well I say some of
the side quests up is is tedious it is
that's why I didn't do someone wow
they're like look man these kids are
missing go find him no I I kid you not I
was doing side quests in Aires hometown
yeah and I talked to the chichi like
look for the kids for me I looked at her
I looked at was like now I'm gonna go
over here and start the main quest we
gotta go super chat pixel bid G $2.00
super chat side quest in which you three
are damn near full story oh yeah we got
we got we got some runs we got weapon
will run to you to build it man Lord BG
get my good baby yeah what's up yeah see
ya I can't you there yo so we got talk
to you if I give it to solve man I see
you you putting that work in playing to
go that was good I wish you feel it
honestly all final fans are you far you
and then yeah what's your feeling open
it I'm on chapter 14 there's 18 chapters
okay I think there is yeah in the game
clock the game clock and final fantasy
actually tells you the the amount of
time you exactly played it doesn't count
the like your time in the menu so I have
28 hours literally played at least seven
hours a day so I can't tell you the last
time I've ever done that sit down I'll
play a game like doom eternal came home
plate for like three four hours
you know in a couple days I'd sit down
play for an hour and a half like last
night I come home I was like man I ate I
hooked it up and then I turn around like
it is five o'clock in the morning Excel
got to go to bed let's look to it will
you watch a live stream because you were
saying something about you got the key
cold and you know you gave out the
shout-out to Square Enix and but you
couldn't do it until Thursday and I
think that Thursday had something to do
up and watch the livestream that day but
I was I definitely wanted to min to see
it you know I don't normally do it so
let's get to it
I'm low key like a little bit like that
for four days so what what why are you
so addicted why can't you put it down
it's it's so good man I mean the combat
is great the content that they've added
is not I know people I think some people
want it to be filler it's really not
it's it's it adds substance and adds to
the to the plot that we knew in the
original even that even the side mission
that addict was talking about the
teacher that the one that the teacher
asked you to you know find a kid here
she says something at the end
mm-hmm that adds to to the plot and I
don't know I'm not I'm pretty sure you
have to find the kids for her to tell
you or I think and it's something about
one of the members of a lineage I don't
want to screw and then later on in the
game
one of the members of avalanche says it
and you're like oh okay so in because a
lot of the game is fleshing out the
characters analysis because in the
original it was like okay they're you
know they're part of the Avalanche crew
you know they're fighting for the planet
more or less that's that's kind of it
you know what I didn't know until this
game
I always thought Avalanche was Barrett
Jesse Briggs and wedge into it like
that's literally I thought no like they
literally like a subdivision yeah
they're like a huge game there's a quick
cuz yeah I don't want to spoil but this
that one part I got to it I'm like yo
what's this is a whole Nova team my
avalanche is not happy with this so like
wait you want that in the original game
I was like this doesn't make complete
sense like three people oh five I guess
can't do all of this is this not
possible good so it makes for sense in
this game mmm-hmm USAF our get your
point about the the teacher telling you
that something in the game I'm all fine
with that and I and I like the fact that
it does add to the story but at the same
time like I'd rather not go find your
kids for you like it I hope you have a
better mission for me to do before you
tell me that snip it and the cats to the
cat he can I go for the castles ability
is I found to the cats it was it was it
was wedges cats or bring no no I was a
little girl you know I I find two of
them because me just naturally walking
around getting and they're like well
we're still missing cats nah you can
find the last cat I found okay let's see
what check gave it attic be like fine
your own damn kids just ate the Maury
show I am I am also addicted to the game
as well like I can't like I think about
it like when I'm away from it I'm
thinking you know when we get back to it
right now I want to just play they've
changed so many so much in the game that
it's a new experience like I get this
old nostalgic feel because of these
characters but I'm getting new
experiences that's why I keep arguing
with people on Twitter look it's worth
it's $60 price is lengthy and it has
substance I don't understand why people
are so like hooked on this whole thing
that it's a fractured game I shouldn't
pay for you know a third of it
well when the game is gonna be 35 plus
hours long and it's good with new
content and new experiences I'm all for
it no doubt no doubt let's get back you
later yeah the side missions like like
especially early on in the first they
get better though I will say yeah yeah
and in the slums you know when you get
the tifa's bar and everything get
everything like that that the side
missions in that area they're very much
like almost tutorial like so I got it
I'm like they are teaching you a lot of
basics and yeah they're not the best
side mission some of the side missions
are good like I said some of them aren't
the combat in the game you know I think
it's real good the aerial combat needs
some improvement is that's very nice I
hate the arrow it's it's like very plain
just wait you ain't even got to the most
annoying thing you know the people with
the proposed I hate fighting them
because I miss them half the time I
don't know about you I don't use like
the the magics of stuff to it we'll see
the thing is is this game is all about
endurance right like you don't want to
use stuff and I'm just like I've sitting
there after after they've almost killed
me I'm like Thunder you're supposed to
be using that assess materia and then
y'all just snitch all what the weakness
is when you get later on the game
there's so many enemies you can't
lightening everything like and you have
to fight something straight on also some
of these enemies they shield and even
with the yeah it hurt Braves you know
like the little magic blue things I hate
those things cuz they switch back and
forth for me you could do damage on
physical you can do damage on a magic
attack yeah and you just want to
sometimes want a Savior your MP
especially these are like basic enemies
yeah in the original game like I should
like this is like little run away like
Braga I really got to chase this thing
down with the tracking the tracking in
the aerial combat is just bad like it's
not even like these things are moving
fast in the air they're like merely
you know jump up and they move you know
what's kind of cool though that I like
the nostalgic feel you get when you see
something they bring back that you
didn't think they would bring bells like
you know which that motorcycle can
appreciate there's some crazy stuff that
happens in that original final fantasy
you're like there's no way you're gonna
fight that again and then you see it
you're like okay it's good I love how
they took little characters like the
thing you fight in this uber and the
original one and they expand on it
they're like because then the original
one you just fought it they can give you
a whole lot of detail but on here like
that's his pet he actually talks to that
thing like I enjoy things like yeah and
like and like there's even parts where
the game acknowledges parts that don't
necessarily make sense like like like I
don't know how to say what else for this
like yeah you know like some of the
bosses some of the bosses and they're
like you did you really fight that like
how could you fight that this thing
doesn't yes yes and to exist the game
you know acknowledges that you know yes
it does cloud itself yeah yeah and it's
like as far as like people saying like
the game is a ripoff or it isn't worth
it I'm like it's complete nonsense like
if you're enjoying the content you play
how can you be ripped off in Phoenix if
you feel that you got your money's worth
for what for what the game was you
cannot be ripped off okay it is it's no
different than from like I enjoyed
Resident Evil three resident evil 3
remake is a six hour game right and and
most people pay paid $45 to $60 now yes
it's a complete game but and I'm not
knocking any anybody would arrive to
sixty I did writen I don't I don't feel
what you but but I don't think you can
tell me that a game that I have thirty
hours and already mm-hmm and I haven't
be in it and I that $60 but Resident
Evil 3 remake just just because it's
quote-unquote complete makes it more
worth it than a game that's five times
longer than or how about when they tell
you look we're gonna have
a whole series of a particular game
they've already announced that they're
gonna make several gotta war games does
it make it bad when that first one comes
out and you buy it on the Psy well I was
absolutely pissed off because don't show
me something and I'll pay for this game
don't show me something that's in the
goddamn funny thing is it's on the table
you can see it but it's like it's like
Odin says no okay we won't go there
Holden says no it was Sony didn't have
enough spider-man was Game of the Year
I'm just saying they're continuing that
stories oh are you ripped off because
you played God of War the only
difference with Final Fantasy 7 remake
is there is an existing copy of this
game around you know in it's like oh
it's like I said they could have easily
have just uh prized everything and just
gave us a 1 for 1 game and you know I in
a world where I haven't played this I
would be ok with that but now I want you
know what what man you know what then to
be honest with you BG I don't even look
at like people playing games I'm not
into that but I said I'm gonna watch
your stream because you know you know
they gave me Kiko and stuff like that
and is you I've added you to some of my
content creators then I watch right you
know I don't watch a lot of people but
you know I try to get in as much people
as I possibly can you know down on out
of respect out of you know our craft you
understand and um so I'm hearing all
y'all talk about this I'm not gonna
front it didn't move the needle because
I was about to go get the game
let me explain why I did right and what
I'm hearing you guys talk about your
having such great fun right yes and it's
been 30 hours of this game and that's
that magnificent that's fantastic
I didn't finish resident evil 2 remake
right so this is the reason why I didn't
buy three sit until a fight cuz you
can't justify yeah exactly I can't
justify that right but then this is the
same thing where the fraud or comes in
with me alright this remake of a game
that Island resident will - that I said
looks amazing looks like in the end I
see Final Fantasy that's right now
I saw somebody put up a meme it was I
think was PlayStation bro of the new
cloud hold in the old clock yes with the
head yes yes yeah and he was walking
with him
yes and I said you clown you sat here
and remember when they first showed you
the trailer before when we was coming
when we first got our Playstations but
before and we saw the Silicon Graphics
well it looks like that now
yes polygons I guess some weird big risk
they had to rob liefeld wrists you know
what this is what a fraud comes in
formulation these actual ganking or
games that actions you know these new
guys that are walking into this world
and these new guys that are actually
playing Resident Evil let's say they
never played before that's the biggest
thing I think people keep forgetting
sure the hardcore US has been around
especially you guys been around for like
10-15 years longer than me you know we
know that there's an original but people
my brother the PDA don't even know they
have no idea but here's the good part
first times the good part you're gonna
like King and I talked to
this with adequate flan is that it's
really not a real it's an adaptation
it's not one-to-one
yeah like because you're gonna get
there's people that don't exist that's
in the game but I'm like I have to hit
this was due me to fight this captive is
this captain he's like I didn't even
exist I've heard that's my whole reason
my whole reason was younger me right
looking at that mean it just took that
one meme to see it yeah and say I need
to wake up yeah I'm standing on a
soapbox that really doesn't roll you put
onto Final Fantasy's ever like you what
the Japanese version first and it that
that made people like me who weren't
into i'ma keep it real I was JRPG fraud
and pride AI maybe I play fantasy star
here and there maybe I play stuff like
that but that gay the reason why I know
y'all like y'all hero on this go talk
but you not understand that's what made
people by JRPGs that game opened the
door up to say okay let me look at six
let me look at three let me look at all
these other junior B did that's the
importance of Final Fantasy that people
have to respect and if it wasn't for you
King who had the Japanese version and I
let me see what this is and I got full I
thought it was an action game right what
is this a regular action adventure game
but ended I'm like oh this is some quest
turn base but you always kind of fight
yes but to be I think you'll even one do
it let me touch King I got a job because
I don't mean that turn-based I often I
am a traditionalist with the old school
stuff so when they was talking about
this new battle system ya know so I said
let me just try to see what it is you
know King it is the most fire switching
abilities on the fly going from each
character then each character has its
own different things they could use in
different situations and long distance
in short I'm telling you man that new
battle system is fine and then you can
switch and then it has a little bit of
pause it goes into slow motion while
you're thinking about your next move it
is really and I saved my life because
from man you can ask BD some of these
enemies they surgically put them
together to give you a headache
Hodel hoto slow-mo I gotta ask BG this
never give it this off
slow-mo says gay what are you it's my
game with you right now
Wow I haven't played other games it's
coming out you know cypherpunks coming
out last of us tubes coming out but all
I'm saying is the bar has been set hard
is for me too okay you know these other
games is coming out this year November
December that's my ball it down on the
screen I think when it comes to this
type of style mmm
get used to it because I do think that
when they after they finish seven
they're gonna do six or nine or
something like that
Chrono Trigger gets remade or pre-made
this is gonna happen to that ii don't
think it's not like the difference is is
this type of gameplay back then is
almost impossible to bring it to this
this timeframe I mean think about the
open-world by itself think about when
you look at Midgar in the old game and
all the unnecessary like what are you
supposed to do for all that stuff you
have to make a game you're happy that
you guys are having fun oh you know
because it had to respect me because I
was making he can like that we're
enjoying it without dog 30 hours in this
quarantine state currency we will be
doing it
let me tell you something thirty hours
to make you forget about what's going on
boy I'll fax it this does definitely
need it and I have not heard not one
person that has purchased the game or
tried to game said anything bad about
the game
so Who am I to say oh you don't don't do
that you know real quick I gotta pay the
bills silsila with the two dollar super
chat give me cold chicken I'll live till
96 for that no doubt you're it's like I
said like you know right now people you
know because of the separating story as
long as they do it as well as they did
this and they tell the entire story now
here's a question I want to ask the cast
especially newbies you let's say that
they have a plan for this game for two
to three games but you know they speed
up the rest of story or you have to wait
four to five games to get the game in
this type of quality throughout the
whole story
what would you be okay with because I
mean you know we're looking like ten
years for a complete game or three for
you know a game that's not necessarily
the quality that we have for this game I
mean like they clearly likes to have to
sacrifice some quality with this first I
guess you call it the first disc and
especially visually like the bit the
visuals are inconsistent right it's part
that's amazing and then you go look at
the bathroom like wow that cut you're
like a PlayStation well polygon yeah it
could go from Advent Children movies to
like literally ps2 bit usuals like in
certain two things it's crazy but this
like two and three are probably the you
know the parts I prefer like this one is
probably like my least favorite part
only because I don't actually don't like
Aerith I I can't so humor you rather you
about that t4u funny to Platinum the
original one you had to get her Limit
Breaks
yeah you know for those people that play
the original she dies eventually so it's
just like you hate the game
bracele a time it takes two for her to
die dude she is the biggest waste of a
character anyway I gotta hear why busy
do not like photo holder holder I got it
here why I got here why okay so she's a
she's a support character or you know
healing support caring right yes but
when you compare her to other support
healing characters in like other RPGs
she's probably like the worst one out of
them and and for example like an other
like let's take dragon quest 11 which
you know I mean like what was last year
at here before there's there's
characters and like they're only they
can learn if I remember correctly I mean
they can give you
hey moves like hates in increase here in
magical defense your your your your you
know your physical defense and
everything like that and only they can
do it right with Eris she's a healing
character but you have that everybody
else can do what she can do is she she
does a better but her blood here's a
pause get all the foster you're right
about the combat suit scenario she sucks
during college I'd rather have two other
people do right but she's a major part
of the storyline it makes like no but
he's saying father Corey's boy talk
about her as a character
yeah battle she's trash I'll get good at
a good dude we gotta get so I like know
we gotta go let it go with why he likes
Erica that I'll give it to Saul I just I
like Aerith you know she's one of the
characters she I've used turned the
other ones like the only character I've
really never used like consistently and
all the Final Fantasy 7 plays is bear a
temper lately and what's funny is in
this game
merit is my sorority nope as like my
strongest joint Fame I got a lot of I
set up with him that is serious I like
because she she's really helpful with
the stagger bar and she her limit break
that thing has saved me and the most
crazy scenarios
because she owes everyone yo to check
the chat is say a teef over Eric though
oh yeah apt PFAs be like one you love
will t for up she's fast she can seem a
fast so that I soft
we don't interrupted you many times you
have picked up that greatness that goat
in this I need to know how you feeling
I mean I wanted to hate from the
beginning I wanted it because to me you
know all this goat talk I'm not due to
play the older ones first
don't house I'm a sixth to me I suffer
all can't hold a candle or Kefka okay
you on your six landed continue he's the
only person I'll let people attack
except for keep is the only person that
can stand up exactly and for me it's
just I just feel it's story-wise it's a
better game right I respect it I was
there day in D no doubt oh you play so I
played it I liked it I didn't love it
but I understand its importance in the
in the in the entire scheme he won't
respect you respect that damn it
continue and when I started playing one
thing that I fell in love with
immediately let's go was the fact
knowing Spelling's is up again caught me
it's not up on nevermind nevermind it
could to the fact that it took that
world right and and it took moments they
were minuscule in the original game and
expanded upon it that's what I always
want to see I want to see I want to see
world explored completely ass every
every level of society like the way
they've done it well if they've opened
up the entire world
and that makes me care about em about
the world in a way that I don't wanna
let up to one second you what you just
said you know when it hit me or you
really want to something when you go to
the slums I know Fonz didn't like the
slums but why I loved it is I had no
idea they was underneath Midgar like so
I looked up and I saw the backdrop and I
saw it and I'm like yo they really
just wait till you get I'm sure Bobby
geez seen it when they drop one of the
plates like tell it tell them how crazy
that it like like I felt bad soft when
we did did initial mission like they
really explained that in the original
war like you like it made us seem like
you were it made it seem like you were
the good guys in the first round was
like yeah we did some crazy forward to
telling the game Sophos always on to
something continue so Mead I asked I was
afraid of right I was like if they don't
do this to this game if they don't take
it all the way and be like look we're
gonna give you this entire world gonna
make you care about this world we're
gonna make you buy this three four
whatever live how to finish this story I
want to by the end of it care about
these characters and care about this
world in a way that I've never cared
about any Final Fantasy game before
mm-hm and addict I don't want to see
anything else but this oh this level of
it it is absolutely bananas like the so
the things that I don't like bright ah
the voice acting is up and down I'm will
take it yeah I'm with you
that's my negative yeah I like better I
actually have issues with cloud
awkwardness but continue this works for
me sometimes because when he says
something funny and he has just a
straight face on like when isn't the
part one wedge gets hurt a little bit
good and he looks straight up at him
he's like I'm sorry about your Blanc and
he says it was such a straight face I
burst out laughing why he's like that
cuz cloud like he actually has mental
issues right the writing it's not gets
lost in translation as well like screen
writing I think some of them writing I
will say does it get close to
translation doesn't necessarily all the
way
the dialogue always like represented so
imagine somebody's trying to act that
out and yeah what the hell do I convey
here yes so that's why I asked my issue
with Barrett I don't marry it's like
it's just like it's 23 years later I
don't know mr. t again and I know he
gets progressively better right yes this
is better than the beginning I don't
need that again so that aside though my
biggest gripe with the funny thing is I
think bear who's my life okay I get it
i my thing is my general biases JRPGs
I'm kind of over them right although
anything that involves like tedious
grind and work like I got excited they
have to do it um but then when you
compare to to The Witcher that teeth
that's my boy that's my part for
creating a world that you're invested in
all the way around because dude this
this side question admissions definitely
needed to be improved wrap around that
wrap around to the main Guinea little
side quests that you may not ever find
in The Witcher could wrap around overall
to the main story art so if there's
anything I want them to continue to
improve with this formula is that and I
don't know that it's gonna happen
because it's still at its heart a JRPG
right but can I can I add to that side
mission issue because I just thought
about something cuz in the original game
you know you're able to if you don't do
certain things you won't even get
certain characters in your party alright
so if you're not doing some of these
side missions in the future you may want
to rethink that because you may miss out
on getting the character right so I also
I'm questioning if they'll ever if
because it's clearly that they wanted to
make this game more accessible right
because there's even parts where if
you're about to leave an area there was
like one part where bear oh hey don't
you want to go get that I'm questioning
on the future disc if they'll like make
it optional though I feel like they're
probably gonna try to lead the player
very much to get all the characters
right okay so yeah I think I think they
will do they'll make it so that's linear
enough where it will
take you down that that path that gets
you every everything and everyone know
and I that's my kind of again that's
Miami beef with JRPGs as opposed to
Western RPGs
I think the Western RPG like even when
you look at things like you know I
submit sure like we look at the Baldur's
Gate games like you can literally do
anything games like anything you can
probably do and I know that's not a JRPG
thing Jeremy geez are generally more
linear and grindy I'm just sort of over
it but that said everything else about
the game is driving me for one of the
positives let me go over a couple of the
negatives because this game does have
negatives peace love me kognito tries it
talked me off off the wall no I don't
like I know that they announced this
early I still don't like the fact that
we read 13's on your party I think
that's why it they they could Toby three
years ago I'm still not gonna like you
know it is what it is I'm not gonna be
able to play with him to the next game
but I still don't like the fact that I
couldn't play with them this game
doesn't but you know another big thing
that I really like about it is the fact
that you know yeah some of the dialogue
can be cheesy at times but the character
development here is so much more than it
was in the first and like jesse was
trying so hard that I was REO shadow
shadow to jesse shoot the shots be oh
dude there's a lot of shot shooting in
this game first of all with PlayStation
I gotta don't trust nobody over that
network no I don't agree with the plate
following thing because that was in the
original if you in play game twenty
years ago but we were I will stay away
from stuff that happens in this game I
don't like the summon system I
understand why
humming system okay we're never gonna do
it continue all about to say that yeah
like yeah like dog well I don't know if
it's the same but I don't like that okay
everything in the game is pretty to do
anything in battle you needed a tan ATB
bar right okay I think I think items
shouldn't count on that I think I agree
item shouldn't I'm with you on it that's
what I thought okay items special move
everything everything you need a TV for
a TV I get my first summit to do a
special move on a summon that you
already summoned oh I gotta use the
a-team
yeah yeah that's why I'm with you here
Ivy you write your but I will say this
can I count it oh can I count it you're
making good points y'all right dad that
shouldn't be that way
the only thing I will say though and I
know father's with me on this I feel
that let's be real if they made it one
to one Final Fantasy 7 you'll be
fighting snails and throw up Leviathan
at any time you know I'm saying so it
loses the flavor like to me when I'm in
an epic battle to miss I know you it
builds the tension so now I'm like you I
need my most powerful thing now is it a
better way to implement it yes but I
feel it fit what I throw it for it down
in the middle of a hard battle it is
such a satisfying feeling now to get to
some that's all I'm saying but I hear we
we all know why they did it uh it's a
casual market thing like they literally
cuz and every time you do a hard fight
they're like yo you getting beat we got
this something for you I don't like the
fact you know and I understand like just
cuz I don't like this stuff I know I
understand why they don't like it oh I
don't like the fact that they they took
all material out the game I know that
they replace it with something else but
I felt like the all material was so
relevant to the franchise that I don't
care what they just changed the name
alone is upsetting I get why they did it
it's called magnet or so but the almond
like lore BG is the all material of
material in the original oh yeah
absolutely people used to go like
through crazy extinct
that um and apply it to everything they
had couldn't you hold on to your limits
and everything in the original yeah yeah
I believe so yeah I agree yeah yeah I
didn't like that the ATB bar resets
every single encounter that's why you
got a hat
you gotta put Eternia that makes your
bar go up half way before the fight so
sometimes I'll be getting I like I'll be
almost dead and I'll be sitting there
like one character running around like
man I gotta go in on this Dube or 30 HP
just to get one sucking he'll myself
like you know I get that in the last
thing thing you know I had it picked on
it is I understand why they did this and
what they did with it it's phenomenal
some are giving it but you know it's
coming from a JRPG man I don't like this
selection of weapons in the game like I
love what they did with the weapon
system I just don't like that there's so
less of them there's like five or six
what is because they have to they have
to carry out all the weapons throughout
all the game so that's why there I got a
shout somebody out rook shot my boy Joe
hit Cox in a building Kelley 303 my mace
I have seen of it it said I said
memories you know about that final
fantasy life continued but that's all
like you know I have to say that I
really you guys remember me a couple
years ago I was worried about this guy
I was like cuz I I said after Kingdom
Hearts 3 came out I was like square you
guys 7 if you mess up 7 I'm done done
done I love how different and varied the
boss fights are - yeah you have to come
at them at certain way different ways
you can't just fight everything the same
way this game is this games one of those
things that it's like if you if you
don't take the weakness to some of these
people like the ghost you're gonna get
wrong you'll get right you're gonna get
right let me jump in real quick then we
move along here's a dick like yog know
it's like it's like font like Final
Fantasy 7 that's my Monalisa
like that's my joint understand so when
you hit a remaking it I'm lying I might
be cast grabbing like what y'all doing
so once we got that demo I was like okay
we lead they this is this is different
this is something special happening
I didn't think they'd be able to do it
and just like I said playing I got I'm
like baby Chapter eight right now
whatever it is and it's just been
absolutely spectacular each part getting
to each story each character development
the excitement the music the combat
system is absolutely amazing I mean it
is truly there they're doing it you know
I'm saying now yes we have something
pictures everything perfect no but Oh
y'all Final Fantasy 6 there's way way
way way way way more pong explain
something to y'all right yeah I could
say all that of stuff all that - I get
it but you understand if it wasn't for
the coop the mainstream to do Bros the
jocks nobody in the hood wasn't gonna
play no JRPGs into this cave that's not
it's the cult that is literally it like
it mainstreamed something that wasn't
cool JRPGs was not cool that's the facts
busy slow Porsche power it was of coming
that job your beloved six yeah listen I
get it six is for y'all but is no seven
is no six no one's gonna pay y'all so
I've said this from day one if six was
considered better by Square it would
have made that business they know what
the business is you don't say but anyway
enough bloviating talk about so what
question I gotta ask though and I gotta
ask seriously cuz I I have come on this
show I have made statements I go for a
self I've made this a very strong
statement remakes cannot win game of the
year I've stood on this square and I go
live this is the first time I'm looking
shaky this game man the firt man I hit
up addict I'm like man break to them let
me bring it to do can a part of a game I
gotta bring it to pause bluesy song
what's up y'all talk to me yeah why not
man
at the end of the day it's like I said
it's new experiences within this old
like a shell of a game like this is not
the same Final Fantasy 7 it's you know
it's got the same characters it's got
more characters it's more story it's got
more development here it's just a brand
new experience I can't see anybody
saying that it's good we've got we've
got to see at the end of the day what's
gonna happen you know we gotta see what
the states with the final super Chad
King this fado fatty 7 is good at all
with that one so a drug is delicious all
right I got I got a BG part of a game
can this rigged game of the year
yeah I mean it's it's I will say it is
it does get a little weird when you get
to the future parts and okay you gonna
have part two and three being nominated
it's just gonna look weird so good not
against it what it if a part of a game
wins game of the year that just means
other games new appreciation do you save
the barrage save the barrage my bro I
can't wait for that second and third
part man bears in 2040 when we get the
end of it no no no that's what we get in
the UM the Xbox series Pro is this isn't
gonna end
I can guarantee you after seven six is
gonna be coming out if they go sped ten
years my kiss hopefully they make three
because three was my favorite that's
when they introduced a job system yes
off can't part of the game with game of
the year
oh yeah I'm not opposed to it at all but
I don't I don't think it's gonna do it
yeah I'm gonna be honest I have not
played cyberpunk
I mean yeah but I'm gonna tell you this
everything that they've shown
that game to be and the level of
interaction and detail in the world and
the side quests and everything about
that world and I get for me like that
that's what I look for
I don't know that in that regard is
gonna hold a candle to it but what I'm
not opposed to it at all they and if it
they could do the thing with it that
they did with it you know Lord of the
Rings well they just waited to return
that the King to give it the you know
the the picture of the year right better
oh but I don't have an issue with it at
all
and I heard this one ends in a way that
makes it feel like a game unto itself a
complete game onto it so addict you
could you'll reserve a judgement until
you see the ended right no I think I
think any game can get game here it
doesn't matter what it is I personally
feel like you know remakes have a little
bit more of a mountain decline the only
games that I could see like it's like I
said last year I don't personally think
remakes you get it but you know I still
have that stance but I do want to adjust
it a little bit like if the game is good
enough if you get it like Resident Evil
2 it was a phenomenal game it was a huge
difference from the first one so you
know it deserved the nomination Final
Fantasy 7 same thing you know it's not I
don't know feel win it okay alright cake
and eat your CAD part of a game with
Game of the Year no conversation about
first of all a part of the game and no
remixes let it go let the remix go you
know listen okay you putting up an
original game against something I
already had sauce materia alright I'm
gonna wake up and then you come up with
this nostalgic game from scratch that
they worked on very hard and came up
with a good experience for you in this
game of the year yes 25 years ago so
let's let's leave it back there and
enjoy what she was doing now
if the goal is a was to go back then you
know you dues took source materials of a
bar they they they drinking it back sir
let me state that you're not referring
to just Final Fantasy seven you
referring to anything it was a source
material and they had a template and all
built off that you didn't do anything
with your do Metro said if it with its
asterisk or put it you gotta put an
asterisk on oh it's nice that you
playing the game good enjoy the game but
always like they did some original you
order some you're sorry you order some
you guys listen it's painful I gotta get
my balls off the world in the question
listen
King is on to something and list I will
say this this game challenged my own
thought process on it like this game is
so good that it challenged my own made
me almost switch position and all that
so I see you dizzy but I gotta be real
kick is right I can't i if it wins it
Friday that I didn't vote it was a I
personally can't do it because there's
existing source material I'm saying but
I will say this game is so done so well
that it challenges that but I can't to
the letter of the law you know how I
feel I cannot give it that but it's
amazing it's amazing I will I will say
it's amazing that's all I gotta add
Italy want to give it to you before you
move on yeah I just want to ask a quick
question you know because to me do you
guys feel like that this remake is
changing the definition where we make it
it's like cuz yeah I feel like you know
between this and resident evil 3 to like
that's that's the go-to now you don't
have that don't even try it yeah yeah I
think it's true I don't just straight
over bastard just really yeah it's over
now like yeah I was super happy with
with the sound of the Colossus you know
they call that um remake consider that a
remake - right but the thing is the game
is descent it's it's the same thing just
the assets of
completely different what it is these
would you consider that now a remaster
and dislike a remake this is okay those
or what y'all playing these games are
remakes they're retelling of the story
right remasters is just up resonate or
metal next generation I'm telling you
now like you're gonna see a ton of that
stuff popping up is not over get off on
me Fox rebuttal the king in that whole
situation about that remaster can't be
you know out there for Game of the Year
you know you gotta look at it as this
they've got people working on this game
it's a completely revamped game it's got
so many different parts to the story
here is there a basic you know is there
some source material that were enough of
sure but there is a lot they've added
into it blood sweat and tears into and
and and if you look at anywhere else in
the industry hell remake some movies
have been nominated for movie of the
year they've won movie of the year it's
happened or so I mean I don't see where
there's any difference in this medium
you know it's if it's a great game
nonetheless yeah if it's fantastic
it could win game of the year this is
what I'm talking about right I'm talking
about taking something original this is
where I'm not discounting the hard work
of the individuals that put forth their
efforts right because they did have to
come up with the enemy they did have to
do their job well what I'm talking about
is if you have an original free style
you have an original ball you have the
Kendrick Lamar dropping out that debt
that that that joint that now then you
got somebody that came from the bushes
spit and Nas eat them with a little
twist on it but with a different beat my
man I can't give you can't go with a hit
above me baby this is more like somebody
taking somebody else's beat and doing it
better
I mean not to go against what you're
saying because what you're saying is
your opinion and you already tasted the
flavor so you already drinking all
kool-aid
all right so me personally from the
outside looking I said yo I will play
the game and I will give it
och you late and then we can definitely
be nominated but then if I'm looking at
that original do did you know I can't I
can't give shield over healed I can't
give sheath over source material that
was all like don't get me wrong you may
have expounded you may have thrown more
stuff on it but if you did have that
foundation that you trace it you trace
it around okay so if you're saying like
let's say they did this right let's say
they took this and it wasn't Final
Fantasy seven mm-hmm let's say it was
Final Fantasy whatever then the whatever
the next number they're like 15 or
whatever that was and they crafted an
original story with these assets and
then I could be like your game of the
year right then I can be like yo that's
what's up
but when you say you're going to use
nostalgia first of all you already got
the Miss nomer it's definitely nice out
you don't could say it's not like
nostalgia multiple times in the game I
do think they're too stupid because
there's gonna be so many of these we're
gonna have a real master character
category like the remastered year it's
not a remaster this is a remake there's
so right now it remains yes right now I
still stand with you guys like at the
end of the day like you know you can
draw a picture a lot nicer at the end of
the day if you draw the exact same thing
still that right right I think that you
know because the nostalgia moments were
getting it's not like these are new
characters besides the dude from the
beginning like you know it's Steph are
all still in here Klaus - you're stolen
here these are still captured it's just
it looks nicer it's gonna be interesting
like the other day you look at a new man
everyone
listen man it's a good discussion it's a
testament to me to how great the game is
that we it's even in the mix and then
people will split people feel you know
just like Fonz you know people feel like
me and King I get it you know I'm saying
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens at the game was with this let me
address something oh that's in the chat
okay um Brian Ingram okay um he
definitely said you know hit that like
button
yes 190 some police here watching you
know um they're going crazy over this
final fantasy please hit the like button
they get a chance to play going crazy
over it now I gotta be honest to them
you know Final Fantasy 7 remake would
have a hell of a time win in any game of
the year this year if you do have The
Last of Us don't be a going
let's go cuz I definitely that's one
game I really have to see in that easy
what what is about I really wanted to
see the sadness of what I'm talking
about see that's an original joint you
know it's based off for the original and
it looks good yo King you got super
check you could put makeup on a pig but
it's use also only do therefore switch
topics you out here Jonathan being for
the crown I gotta you good because we go
move or if you get new controllers in
the building y'all you know sir Sony has
dropped in now submit the dual sent it's
no more dual shock that white butters
that came through was very controversial
and social video but it came through a
lot of cool new features you know and
I'm saying so um yeah they call it a
dual sense man a lot of on looking at
the the feature set right now we've got
the adaptive triggers you got your
create but no bush
I'm saying we're going to USBC touch bad
you know all the likes economically a
little different audio coming from the
controller itself so yet if they've
released it man so the streets are
buzzing I want to get this over the Lord
funds what do we think about sets do
they have sense are we really gonna like
bolster up our rumble feature ff6 is
still King
suplex a train come on man we will read
thank you when you remake coming out all
right consider so like I said I'll at me
when you get a remake release date day
we could talk about it - go ahead go to
there I've been thinking about that
controller and you know this whole sense
thing and how they've added these rumble
features and I mean kids at the end of
the day I mean the switch has these
rumble features that do certain things
everything is it that innovative and
great not really I mean is this thing
really gonna take off based on some new
rumbles I will say though that be today
defense funds I mean no one has that
that what is it adaptive trigger like
that they say like that's cool with the
bowl how I wanna get to like that the
rest of the rumbles but the controller
the way it looks itself I actually like
the way a little oh you like that like
the way it looks
except for that white okay make that
black big ass think about it is gonna be
out there with cheeto fingers getting
those grooves that's not gonna be a good
look I'm not down with the white
controller they need to change that up
I'm come the way it looks the form
factor it looks kind of like an Xbox
controller
they had to do is place that left yeah
that's the one problem I have with the
Sony controller like I like their
triggers and stuff but I do not like the
the analog placements I wish they would
move that you know what they never will
but that's just a personal opinion but
yeah as far as like the sense controller
and that's all gimmicky to stitch 669
2010 Sony has a partnership with Fisher
Price bushes Oh Lord boomstick XL
double-barrel gaming fine on a super
chair just wanted everyone whichever on
a panel and in the chat a very happy
Easter from businesses investors
boomstick I salute my brother-in-law
boosting Excel help oh one more thing I
wanted to point out about they control
what happened to that screen they were
supposed to be on it just rates and
elusive it's called battery life no this
is better than the DualShock for battery
life yeah yeah we go see Lord addict man
would you feel about the dual sense
oh we have this rumble feature or
anything like that I didn't click any
article I looked at the page chair I was
like I can rock with that and then
clicked right off salute salute Lord
solve where we at does it have sense
enough sense for you listen these
features I'm very glad that Xbox has
taken the features in their controllers
and just incrementally made them
slightly better things that you can sort
of see in real like real life
performance improvements that aren't
like out-of-this-world crazy promises
like you know like when we saw HD rumble
in the switch it got you like - and that
was it and it was cool dude what a guy
why - game time was this I don't know
that stuff is really gonna be
implemented or and and
laughs maybe maybe the first batch of
first party games coming out before it
really implemented right and really but
I just think it's not something remember
the impulse triggers on that exactly
exactly so it's like I don't know I
beyond that you know what is hyperbole
talks if their stuff listen I will eat
crow if the stuff is really
game-changing yeah I really will um the
look of it I'm not a fan of 2-tone
completely which better be okay with
that because I have a feeling the
console about to look well we don't and
that's the thing right like the consoles
gonna be 2-tone it literally looks like
the controller is wearing like a little
black dress like it slipped on like a
little black dress above above the white
the means lit on sweater with this
controller mm-hmm let me ask you a
question let's say the 2-tone controller
may have now youth it once it they flip
it on you once that they give you the
option of them reversed like both of
them like the black I just want a black
console that's it well everything in my
room black I completely understand I
just want to think even like again the
the 1s is a beautiful console the yeah
the 360 the white would the off-white
was kind of a little off-putting at
first but you get used to it it's very
nice but it gets super dirty it gets
super dusty white concers only really
need to come out later on as your first
foray out the door yeah that looks I'll
doubt about that even that you just
gotta be what's what's more aesthetic
approved like Dan even know said hate is
real they say we hate you this is the
one time I'm giving you permission but
why you think we're hating in that
comment I'll read and when you have to
be a super tippet you better say
something like actually that makes sense
let me guess room for the $2 super jet
true Kingdom looks like a fan-made
prototype the tech is cool though
the first time I saw it I actually
thought it was like a generic like
something made by like what's that
company that does generic stuff told you
be like the home I know you took I think
it they named the third-party Jake that
using make everybody could show yeah
when I saw that I was like oh there make
it go back I didn't know I did I look at
it let me explain how I saw this okay
I knew this is a heart talk because
normally I see stuff before on Twitter
way before Facebook so I'm on facebook
I'm scrolling through Facebook and I see
a controller I'm like I'm like that
looks like Generic and I looking in the
picture it says PlayStation and I'm just
like whoa Golu I go straight to Twitter
and I look up straight Playstations and
I'm like they really announced they
controller and I'm looking at like the
controller album do ya got a stop at the
after boy yo [ __ ] just say afterglow
stop it it looks like that controller
that you buy our original Xbox yes and
you have money for three original
facilities and the fourth one had to be
the Mac I'm looking at the controller
and I'm just like first off I don't get
the Xbox controller vibe to it I don't
know why maybe it's just because as long
as long as the sticks are in the
position they are that it's always gonna
be a place to actually control it yeah
if you look at it from the sideways
angle it looks like a dough shock for
slightly different right yeah it seems
like it's more ergonomic overall like
you're not right up it is kind of angled
a little bit and it does look cheaply
made right now just
and I think it's just a just a little in
a color
you know Tony ain't gonna do something
that's gonna hurt their brand this thing
gonna be fire you're gonna put your head
like I would think that they would even
like making gray or something like the
original colors I prefer black control a
control on console but give me white
green black a fun gray purple orange I
don't care what color so far as your
main thing is like that color though you
really a color and the fact that they
put a speaker on there another speaker
microphone on there yeah I collect in
need oh Cognito picture this yes
you got all these people with that break
they stand your controller and you and
these parties mmm in these game lobbies
another don't what I don't need to buy
nothing oh yeah let me do what I do
there you go hear their kids and they
dog and he's gonna be put in there's
gonna be a noise cancellation thing
right and I'm like okay cool it picks up
the closest noise well what's the
closest noise - that - that little mic
are you hitting upon yeah yeah and you
know what's funny
berrak tell it's gonna have Noah's
cancellations like I'm like Esther dis
people and Sony's research and
development even go online and play
games people be people be eating Cheetos
listening to music in the background
like I don't want that amplified okay
I'm gonna give it the kingdom it I just
want to say like one would hope that dis
noise cancellation they've had the
foresight to understand that they will
not you know mute what is initially
around which is the you know to analog
what would oh that's what I got to give
it to kids I'm dying to know a kid
thinks about this control okay so from
from the RIP when I saw it I said it
looks nice yeah I love how it looks
I love the 2-tone of it I said okay good
cuz they never get me to talk console
they're not gonna go in a traditional
black yeah they're just trying to
separate this self from Microsoft yeah
you know y'all forget our first
PlayStation was that off grey we're
you know and I thought that was a great
console and they kept that light color
for a long time then they went dark
we had quacky controllers before where
what I was when I heard about the duel
since I got a little bit nervous because
I remembered the sixaxis yeah yes and
that's that came with the PlayStation 3
which was $5.99 and they told you was
gonna revolutionize the world so but
what happened when you got the
PlayStation 3 after a year they started
removing all this stuff off of it and
then the controller it was only like two
games that used that that dragon game
was something else and I'm help me sword
man and um and those are really good
games and it was very nice at the time
but then those you know everybody wasn't
using these features and and I think
that after a while you know nobody else
is gonna be using it because it's one
thing to release call of duty on all
platforms and you'll call the duty when
you're using the bowl nobody kid I
really don't think it's going to change
Microsoft has done the research and they
have the the proper controller going
forward with the features they see it
that I use the most what confused me is
a lot of you hypocrites have been
talking about and I'm calling you
hypocrite because when the Kinect was
out and it was spying on you in a way
they have a freaking microphone right
there crack is that it's crotch level
this is cool for you that you're not
going to talk about that part I think
the microphone get the microphone off
what happen all that talk about oh it
was a screen on battery life I feel that
all right take the screen off remember
y'all was talking all this touchscreen
crap and Wow it's not even being used
it's not even being utilized remember
with the what was that the Vita yeah
it's more the molest of a lesser degree
and it's not even being used listen mark
Cerny is permeating
okay and he's bringing his philosophies
in hold on hold on let me give him his
property Magic Mike Oh like good - he's
doing a dance let me dance moves Jim
right you know where do you pick baby
doing this thing for you mm-hmm I think
this controller is a Trojan horse for
they PR hmm you know because that's the
only way I can see them
tension with a bow and you know surround
sound and all this crap they talking
about
I can only see it working with their VR
and then control is the Trojan horse
because remember in VR the only barrier
between you and the game is the
controller right you're trying to make
the controllers as effortless as
possible
so if they can just sell you a headset
and you already got the controller right
then that's a win so they can actually
get a better headset to you at a cheaper
price
you know then the new ones selling you
the movie with other stuff so I really
think they're onto something I really
like the colors I really like certain
features I wish they will remove the mic
out of the box yeah I'm not pissed off
with it I really like the stuff guys
need to you know because that of a
minute ago mm-hmm Sonny wasn't saying
anything right
so when Xbox is doing their inside Xbox
they drop their controller
I like yes I like aggressive Sony
control out when you're talking about
games make the most noise so yeah please
give me another inside Xbox enjoy this
shows me the charla in this fight
because they want some type of fight and
I actually like that chat real quick
build a crest up Charles Paul to DA
super chat it looks like an Xbox
controller and a fisher-price okay it's
a lute listen I mean at the end of the
day you know I'm kind of whips off I
really feeling I'm not wild by you know
um it's one of them things that I got to
get it in hand first I'm not gonna
completely rip it until I get it in hand
it could feel really good it could be
ergonomic and all that stuff I'm wit far
as I hate hate hate hate the white hate
it with a passion I just wish they chose
another color scheme I'm gonna tell you
right now just a minute dem color waves
go on sale look for four black and other
colors that's the one I'm gonna be using
now with the mic again I'm live far as
like I get it you're giving people an
option they don't necessarily have to
have a mic but it's also I like what
Atticus said it's it's gonna encourage
people to be like I don't need no mic
I'm good I don't want to be a no party
chat Miro what's up just hit me talk
today they ain't even gonna give you
that little dongle thing Mike they had
in the box yeah ain't gonna drop that
mic in there either so now it's like no
it's already on the controller you're
gonna get a lot of dudes out there and
do you think that's the reason that they
put this in there so they can save money
on putting the mics and stuff in there
no I think it's just an extension of
that it's just one of those things where
it takes care two things at once you
right hey we can put them out and we
could microphone so straighten the
bushes well I'll be look I still got a
jack you could I was worried at first
that they wouldn't be able to connect a
microphone thing to it so you Africa
they've confirmed you can you know
you're still so you're still gonna be
able to do it but I hate to let me throw
the pocket watch alright quick I hate to
[ __ ] watch but there's gonna be dudes
who goes say oh I only know Mike fan we
good I'm like I don't want to be in a
party with that dude I don't want to
hear but - did the Doritos I want here
children I wanna hear your dog so Neil
and don't talk to each other so don't
matter boy attic you know this shout out
the kids smooth and all his kids imagine
being in a party with someone on
PlayStation I can already see this
happening I'm not over there a whole lot
but what I am and I could just see me do
go get a mic thank me I love you tag but
imagine like you need the
controller like I can't hear you and
they have to put it up to their mouth
and I want about wanna be about that
life bad oh you'll kiss me laughs it's
not the kid you know it's all chokes me
way worse since King I love you but weak
you you got a hat you cannot not have a
bike with it yeah and you cannot play
with that control my word but you know
they all say I don't kick no like it but
they are saying that the arm adaptive
triggers are better than this series
axes impulse joints so we'll see you
know you draw your bow you get your Tomb
Raider on King you don't get to work for
one at a time they can say all that
until they take it out because what
didn't intend to do they had their
hectic crap ice cubes nobody had to
devil with the ice cube irrelevant is
gimmicky yeah I mean I would in fairness
I want to see it in action
you know I'm say uh hold off would say
it available so to Krista what's a final
a super check first door Sony done lost
a man white flakes face plates or so
2014 second door Sony found a reason for
everyone to purchase an all-black 1/8
set up yo you are the self Woodstock
he's got that right
you're the something you're the but look
that's that's pretty much what I got on
it I mean the last thing is you know
obviously I'm a fan of the Xbox as far
as to stick positioning you know me I
will say I do feel for first-person Xbox
is about getting my jam but I always
liked their d-pad I feel their d-pad for
fighters and stuff like that it's always
tighter you know I mean so we go see
gotta forgot to see how it is wouldn't
win a drop that's all I got on it and we
can move on
Lord South you are up man
cyberpunk situations that's good so so
last week CD Projekt RED had a
conference call sort of basically just
detailing you know how they're dealing
with
production and development during
quarantine and stuff like that and just
basically talking about you know the
success of which are on switch and
things like that so a lot of it was just
financially oriented but they did speak
about more details about how they're
gonna handle the rollout of cyberpunk
mmm
so some interesting things that came out
of the conference call that have been
sort of the internet being the internet
took the stuff and ran with it
so shout out to uh to Paris from the
gamertag wave his specific tweet sort of
got people rolling which was great idea
but so generally what they spoke about
spoke about was a basically timber
launch for the game is still on they're
working on a digital marketing strategy
to basically replace III and sort of get
more messaging about the game out there
um interestingly PC pre-orders are kind
of above and beyond what everybody's
ordering the game are opposed to console
work and they they reiterated what they
were gonna do with smart delivery for
the Xbox Series X and they did
specifically say that those versions of
the game would not be available for the
launch of the console so it's to play
the upgraded version of cyberpunk
day and date when you get your new
console that ain't gonna happen
alright so when they were specific when
they broached the specific topic about
the PS 5 and it's a version of cyberpunk
that would be on the PS 5 they basically
indicated that they weren't gonna talk
about that until so we spoke about it
right whereas from the beginning when
Xbox spoke about smart delivery they
came out and and and wholeheartedly
supported it saying specifically as as
the CD Projekt RED point of view on the
subject they said we don't feel that you
need to buy your game more than once
right oh you're a hundred percent behind
behind smart delivery oh the fact that
they're sort of being mum on this and
sort of leaving the ball in Sony's court
has led many people to believe that the
news behind that isn't something that's
favourable ie there will be a totally
separate skew for cyberpunk 27
seven on PS five you will not be able to
play an upgraded version of it without
paying for it on the PS 5 you can't play
it's four version on it but not
necessarily so again that's speculation
they haven't said your name right a lot
of the thinking behind it is that this
is probably the case so I want to know
what you guys feel about this [ __ ]
ready love cookie but let you
orchestrate kai I would I would normally
give it the kick but I think he's
cooking so he's going to let people talk
so I would give it the funds I haven't
talked to father or door have I seen his
Twitter reactions to this and cyberpunk
is near and dear to both of us so arm
yes we feel man we know about the smart
delivery Xbox has jumped in front of it
saying you will not have to pay and you
know obviously there's conflicting
things here we don't know for sure with
the PlayStation sighs so what your
sisters already started a chat we need
to swipe your card emoji stop it all
right so I wouldn't get to fuss what do
you think's going on um well I mean
obviously you're not gonna have to pay
with the PS 5 as well it's just
something that it'll eventually happen
will it be the day it drops or whatever
on the PS 5 who knows like what's going
on there but we do know that's confirmed
for Xbox that's great for those of us
that are gonna have the series X also I
love the fact that they're just
committed it just seems like CD Projekt
RED are just on another level when it
comes to their commitment just once
yes like I mean a lot of us forget that
they've had previous games before The
Witcher 3 but it's what they've done
with The Witcher 3 in that world and
each DLC the drop
have me confident in this product and
not only that everything that they say -
they know what they're doing everything
they put on Twitter everything they tell
and committee in an interview it's just
they're hitting all the right they're
doing all the right thing you know all
the right things and when it comes down
to it we know now that they're committed
to giving us like really big deal
are already saying all that stuff and I
am just so excited about loli getting
this game like I just want to play it
already
this is my type of game absolutely
there's no Ali this is give me giving me
vibes of like you know mass effect add
on a bigger scale if that makes sense
like it's just rich open-world concept
it's a whole man that just that world
looks incredible I just can't wait to
dive in and I'm glad they kind of pushed
it off because honestly the closer it is
to those new car yes
you know maybe I'll still be playing it
because I can't not I can't write hey
wait yeah but let me guess I'll be able
to play the DLC and everything on the
series X at least I'll be able to play
all that so let me let me ask you this
note to solve point so you feel Sony is
going to let it I feel so I feel they're
gonna get it it's just they're not
saying anything right now because they
they really do have a great relationship
with Microsoft it seems mighty Projekt
RED seems to have a great relationship
okay and we've got the marketing deal I
just think that you know it's one of
those things that's just unspoken right
right okay I see no doubt we have not
talked about this this cyberpunks ps5
you know is it a free upgrade or that
situation the reason when you talked
about it cuz I couldn't care less look
at the other day I I'm gonna have the
call so that gives you the free version
dudes over there if you don't get a free
you might want to insert your card into
the polls why
get the piecewise obviously PlayStation
should give the people that you know
that access but if I got it for you you
you you're telling the gamers that they
need to go to the company that has
talked about it be free and you don't
pay them Amadou is the one that's what
we do it it's not it's not my place to
tell Sony have make money that must be
amazing cuz you gonna breed by
everything multiple times like I do I
think that's Sony's gonna do the free
update sure I do but at the same time we
talking about Sony here they they they
like look we have we have the demand we
had the market we have the share in the
chat like I said we said like we only
have history to go by history let me
give a super to go to catch selfish rule
kick them til I switch at PS 5 we'll
take cash at [ __ ] PayPal get everybody
ready I wouldn't be surprised and I
would think that they would do that you
know but because it just it makes the
most sense the only reason I don't the
only no I'm saying from a competitive
standpoint but the only reason I don't
think they would do something like that
is because this information this isn't
the first time they announced this a
long time ago and not one time because I
remember it being an issue the first
time they announced it when they
announced smart delivery the first time
right and I remember people adding them
like crazy it was training is this gonna
happen to place age is this gonna happen
a Playstation one time to PlayStation
correct anyone yeah one time is
PlayStation corrected anyone now if it's
going to be best it's right I feel like
it's just a tweet but let me ask you
this though it in fairness like what
about what about a situation where okay
we know CD Projekt RED it has to relate
[ __ ] with Microsoft right we know they
they into damn pocket and communicate
and they know and then Microsoft let's
be honest they have been super
forthcoming with Xbox Series X
information right we swap delivery all
these features out open could it be a
situation where Sony has that same
feature and just because they haven't
announced yet
CD Projekt RED could be like yo it's not
all personally is that our place to be
like that now so feature that they
haven't announced themselves it could be
but like I said people want to say go
off the past Microsoft to my knowledge
has never forced someone not to say
something about as something as simple
as a feature of getting their copy that
you've already bought on another
platform you know who has done that sony
Sony wouldn't let Microsoft even promote
destiny one man so you know we're just
gonna have to see at the end of the day
we're gonna have to see how this implies
because they Sony did do something
similar to this with their first party
stuff at the beginning of the
PlayStation 4 but I remember correctly
you still had to buy you know the Last
of Us I don't know what they're gonna do
I don't know what Mike Sony's gonna do
some days I think Sony don't even know
Sun duty right now cuz you think it's
Bobby got some we finally got a little
bit of a glimpse of the Sony that's been
killing Microsoft this whole generation
in the form of a controller so maybe in
the next couple of weeks we'll see more
from them because it seems like you know
they're they're hitting that road
they're heating that confidence where
they're starting to show information all
I'm saying is a simple tweet would have
been suffice to rest they're a huge
audience of this right do I think that
Microsoft is is putting a gun to CD
Projekt right now you better not you
tell them that they better not announce
they have this going on like I don't
think that's happening here I think you
know maybe Microsoft and and maybe
Microsoft approached CD Projekt right
it's like look what are you little money
on my bag yeah we'll throw they got the
band on that back-end you know go over
there I don't know if that's something
that is obligated because it feels like
to me that you have to help support not
really necessarily poor but you know a
yo I'm dead Oh
Oh CD Projekt RED throw their game on
the PlayStation 4 and then and they do a
remastered version a year later and so
said their game on the PS 5 that doesn't
seem like that's a Playstation a
question that seems like that's a CD
Projekt RED to my knowledge CD Projekt
where I'd like stuff like that so I
don't see an issue with that happening
okay look I gotta get this image check
because if the company that's making the
game says that they are for not buying
your game twice then if it's not
happening on Sony's platform that's Sony
that's not CD Projekt RED stopping
interested but let me get this super
said shout-out to Mariano Papa with a
$10 super chair with the new PlayStation
4 controller you could speak your credit
card number trick to the mic
great show as always LeWitt's thanks for
the laughs during these tough salute
hilarious who wouldn't get jealous more
would get jealous you got the next one
okay so we got a $2.00 super chef from
charles paulo who charges for free to
play games and you got a point there you
do you got a point there but it is what
it is hey I can't stop Microsoft from
doing that we've stated multiple times
in this podcast that it's not right for
them doing that but guess what people
still playing that Xbox Live to play
that game so I can't stop them from
doing that just like I can't stop from
Sony for making you pay two copies of
the same thing no ID King you are
cooking I see you bubbling you already
Magic Mike already told you 35 of the
top 100 games edible that we're working
very diligently on CD Projekt RED game
ain't one of them you go ahead the
window you gonna have to get yourself
anyway you can get away diversion you
see the problem when your pockets is
only oh you can't do stuff like the
balla do you know Microsoft say yo
that's the game of the year yo you're
even got by that twice that's on the
house our new joy that's big pocket talk
man you know he's upgrade all the way
you just throw the discus you see what
Microsoft Sony is no Sony thank you so
remember how we trade games just like
that this is how we upgrade games for
free now you see the difference right
you'd see the difference in your man is
on a budget the club he's trying to
drink right so to do with all the money
bleh your drinks on me one drink for me
every sequential drink is gonna get paid
for oh good CD Projekt RED game pong
2077 yes this is it man you want to make
sure cease owning or make sure that you
play the PlayStation first right do you
think it's gonna carry over cuz all the
Microsoft dudes is like okay on to the
next one we're moving on up
and you my friend gonna have to get that
$60 out oh really good Chuck come on
charge you full price you gonna swipe
that card on the sides gonna come
rolling they don't have no thoughts and
give me your backpack
he said 35 at the top 100 games are your
favorites know that you pay for that
game I don't know that it's illegal to
charge for Pat she asked me he said it's
a legality issues game they can't do it
they say it ain't gonna be no patch
enhancement for you nothing you are
legally gonna go to the store and buy a
whole new copies it is this way right
it's a whole new system so it's a whole
new purchase you bought their
PlayStation fine life be about their
places
I can't I can't you do it you do it
listen I got it I gotta scrap on I could
not see a world where they have the
audacity to charge if they do this I
will bid to be I think I gotta jump it
on I gotta defend I by the defense
selves are I cannot see a scenario with
a light Yahoo
Nereo when they do that last of us
they're gonna do it with this massive us
he's gonna come on the PlayStation 4 you
can win a Playstation 5 come out they're
gonna say hey new school is gonna be fun
native 60 frames per second PlayStation
5 it's gonna be yes later knees the
knees don't apply here once again guys
oh you can you can you can play your ps4
version on your PS lay it on your ps4
back hundred of your favorite games that
they're working on 35 they never change
that a baby so they keep changing I'm
gonna take all my disc in and if one of
those games do not work you're back up
at theory is done so if a kid this that
don't work this all gotta be but he only
buys bangers that a bang is gonna work I
want you going out post-mortem and
buying you know like you know whatever
we're gonna do I'm gonna have the GoPro
set up you could see what distant work
for this
I just needed a situation where CD
Projekt RED doesn't want to get in
trouble they're not ready to talk about
it yeah we know Sony hasn't been
forthcoming with ps5 information as much
I think they're just waiting or them to
announce it no the backup at situation
over there get in trouble about you just
don't know you know the fact that they
came out and so added me and I know it
was this was you know this is
predetermined right this is not that
they came out after Microsoft made their
announcement this is all done in
conjunction right but the fact that they
came out and any say yeah oh yeah we're
gonna support that on the Xbox and I
know they came out and they were like
yes we don't believe in it we don't
believe in another way this is the way
it should be
right but so they said should word
should is gonna be the word will is not
being done that way and that's that's
what makes me know this is like at that
point mmm how do they spin their
messaging if Sony goes the other way
right how do they spin it right you know
look too good hey wait a minute you guys
said this is what you about so it means
you didn't fight for this no because it
was the check and they said they won any
case about a game twice listen they
should do it this way and Microsoft is
doing it how it should be done
other guys should get it together but it
is either way we got paid so they we got
it this is gonna be a fun readily cuz I
don't know where this is going this is
hilarious
only got money to throw away it won't
all your cash go to Christocentric
age five dollars of Jack Saudi got a
Olli fans account you gotta pay for this
you gotta relax you gotta relax just to
join them for the day we gotta see
what's gonna happen bet that's all I got
all this when we get to the last topic
King you are up inside Xbox job this
week okay putrid listen my xbox do all
right
let me tell you something what I don't
like is or you to try to make
personality in facts you think that I
need to play this game because someone's
soul thinks this game is cool I don't
care what someone so does you know what
I'm not calling I'm not gonna do calling
out people yet you know because they do
their job it's it was poorly executed in
the fact that not too long ago Microsoft
just did another show show showed game
baby look you tell game campy crap none
of this listen I don't care about that
stuff if you want to do like unboxing
with Larry heard mm-hmm
if you want to do what Major Nelson is
playing tonight do that stuff but if you
want an inside Xbox okay give me inside
Xbox don't get me inside Xbox
personalities yes and and this is where
I find it cringe-worthy y'all goes on a
roll you always hitting on all cylinders
and then you hit the speedy bump again
and seems like y'all can't get past this
one barrier it seems like just that show
though right because they trying to make
person now it is like you care for it I
don't care for the people that you know
that's telling you about the game and
the game itself enough the developer is
talking about the game
tastic with less involvement from a
personality evil and more about the game
I love the games that dish I loved loco
but - the cringe yes that's why I dat
xbox was so good because it literally in
they and they had developers they didn't
even show them they didn't show no
personalities it was the game the
developer talked about his game real
quick wild and all you saw I'm with you
on that King I got a I got a feel you
wanna son let me get a farm a have you
had you've watched yet it's that
ex-boxer know I've seen bits and pieces
of it but I agree with King 100% I've
seen enough of them to know that they're
like that and I don't like it that's one
of the main reasons it's those cast of
characters they have on they're talking
about the stuff like that like I care
about what they like right I don't give
a damn which I just want to play the
game where I wanna hear about the game
mmm
but yeah this lasts inside Xbox as well
just from what I've seen of it wasn't it
wasn't good to me I mean most of the
games they showed damn it sounds like a
de got that controller early from sounds
like you get the controller because
you're talking four-bath yes look yeah
you're on the door sense I feel like
inside Xbox it's like they they try to
be different but then not be different
it's like look you are not direct and
you are not stay to play you've made
this clear we want to take you want to
stretch everything okay then why are you
stretching stuff out that shouldn't be
stretched out and you're not stretching
out stuff that should be stretched out
look if you're gonna do an inside Xbox
and make this a breakdown show cuz
that's pretty much what it is it's a
breakdown show they break down stupid
stuff all the time that no one cares
about why didn't I hear more about Gears
tactics why did I hear more about the
games people care bubble you spent 20
minutes talking about ulama
okay got busy I'll give tactic stove not
really not really
it's were really nice it was just the
stuff that was wrapped around in it now
enough you remove this stuff that's
wrapped around it I can see we're adding
it's talking about and then I got his
tactics what look do a breakdown char
don't do a breakdown show the only good
thing about this inside Xbox is it was
sure I feel like 30 40 minutes yeah they
need to be they need to the less is
better for this type of game yes you you
know the first data I prefer Stata plays
over yeah because I just like to see
game after game the same so like that's
pretty much all look at the end of the
day no one could say anything about what
they're doing they're very I can't
really complain about something when
they're transparent about everything
going into this they're like they're
we're doing this this this and this and
then we're bouncing we're uh just keep
doing that I'm I don't I haven't really
what let's be real here we've been
talking about inside Xbox for a year and
a half they're not gonna change that
doormat they're gonna keep doing what
they do that's okay I guess like they
really use this to promote game pass
like let's be real
like yes I don't care about the inside
Xbox thing anymore mhm
unless it's a game on there this is how
I go about it oh and inside Xbox system
are grounded though cuz I have to get
look better and I love the fact that you
can play with you guys
listen we asked them for original stuff
you can't have your cake and eat it too
you like oh you don't want the Forza the
halo is it the game that I would like to
play no I'd like an actual hardcore RPG
when it comes to that but at the end of
the day I'm not gonna sit here and like
you know dizzy loves this type of game
let him play that letting
uh you know this game actually the way
they showed it look better than the show
to EXO so it's one of those games okay
it's in-game past because try it out
download it try and then probably
uninstall three hours later in everybody
yeah I mean I agree that the grounds
over the ground did it for me I feel
sort of the same way because it's like
you know what it is and I said this last
week Phil talked about he said it over
and over again how listen we didn't have
the most diverse oh yeah absolutely
better games and cake is right on this
case right and by C&S the troops but by
saying that you know you that the
approach is different than Sony's right
right when she only has a small game
like this it gets pushed off to the side
yes like well you know dreams which
isn't a small game but there with no
sort of marketing behind it um concrete
genie came and went on the medieval
remaster who even who might have tell
them not to promote their game we're
sure these I have to accept and
understand it on the Xbox platform these
type of games will get more
front-and-center
than something else I don't really care
I don't think what they're doing in the
inside Xbox is wrong as long as they
keep the main for the I'm going to tell
you what's on this show I saw Gears
tactics okay I'm gonna jump in there
because I want Gears tactics maybe
watching inside Xbox like three of them
because when you see that thing on
Twitter it's like this is what we're
going to talk about that's something
that you're interested to ninja or not
it's gonna be trashed don't watch it
right now so could see some sort of big
takeaways from this one right arm big
game past expanding in Japan and Korea
oh that's what Achtung
thank you that's because when you talk
about markets that where the Xbox brand
is not successful
nothing glares out more than then the
the Far East right we're countin and the
thing about it is it's a good way of
gauging whether it's just the Xbox
weather
Xbox ecosystem - - the attachment of a
console can be successful in those in
those environments where the barrier to
entry is seriously low and well people
it's specifically now right the
situation that we're in now people
people are more open to trying new
things because they're running out of
things to do right all right other
things to do so I think it's an ideal
time to see if the Xbox brand without
without the the anchor of a console in
an environment where they don't care for
the actual console what at work so I
think that's fantastic I mean big time
and then beyond that when it came when
it comes to I agree would addict about
the gears tactics like years tactics is
looking absolutely amazing
oh but it's different I'm doing I'm good
with different spin on it yeah I'm
totally different spin good roller
skates
oh wow I like I like grounded more you
know we always hammer these guys right
we them over and over and over again
let's see if these all that none of
y'all here like that or wanted it lease
it look good really good
I don't think so alright I don't like
them animations I don't like that joy at
all that joint look like Kinect
characters like adventures you running
around I am not fit like if it look good
and animations look good I'm watch ah I
don't think it looked good I just
oh we complain about a lack of Xbox
quality games but we're talking about
quality titles that we want we want to
see triple-a mature games we don't want
there these types of game back phones
don't you think like because these are
end of a core unit and dinner and stuff
right this is stuff that they're gonna
show you right now I don't you know I
think they're coming are coming yeah see
I don't care if a game is like look at
Inside Man besides me is like a
perfectly crafted game this is not this
is not a humongous game yet it took like
six years to make what
I don't know how many people on you know
what game they haven't talked about this
kind of pissed me off that I've been so
excited for it and it's probably a tiny
game mmm 12 minutes yeah well minutes I
don't know look I'll jump in quickly
I'll make it look we talked about the
good arm you know like like soft said
the announcements with arm game past
Japan and PC on South Korea huge huge
repercussions there like that people
don't understand that that permeate in
those markets issues we see it with the
joint after what gears fartiest tactics
look amazing I thought I was I was
thoroughly impressed um I like that it's
what is it Kate's dad Gabe whatever Diaz
or whatever they had a full cinematic
story high production value I was really
in that arm yeah I mean other than that
I mean you know like attic said you tune
in you see what the list is okay cool
but the issue is always going to be the
presentation I'm not gonna let off of
that because they've been so good prior
they've been so good with series X
information and marketing and doing all
this stuff and then here come inside
Xbox and you like fam again King is on
it like too much personalities and I
want to shout out one though Malik was
on fine I like he was actually funny he
was making me laugh some other people
they're not as much you know I just I
don't even think it's a staff one person
that was funny exactly I already would
think it sister I just think it's a
situation where when I turn this on I
don't want to see your face I will see
your face like I want to see your face
in the first five minutes when you tell
us what the lineup is then the screen
goes blank and then show games out and
then at the end we see your face again
when you say to the next week and then
that's what I want now I'm at I'm just
at the point I don't want to see anybody
show what's going on because the reality
is reality is gamers don't care
gamers just want to know what the news
is and what the game is you know I'm
saying that's it now to ground it I just
not there look soluti yeah dudes I love
it if I'm glad they're making something
original I am I will agree with King and
solve that you know at least Xbox is
giving games like that some light where
other companies may not as much maybe
Sony's not as much
just not for me you know I'm just you
know moving on I want obsidians real
Tripoli I should say real the triple a
came that I'm looking for
does put games out like that yeah and
quite often but they push them to the
side they don't really put right line
like Xbox and Xbox is the difference but
here's the thing the reason why Xbox has
to do this is because of game pass yes
game paths they have to be keep quality
or at least quality to some people
content in there and I get it I
understand that not every game can be a
triple-a prosperously
that's what so it is good that they're
putting them in there and yes it sheds a
little it puts a little spotlight on the
studios and absolutely a so-so
I mean you know it's it's a good thing
in the end but if I want those big
triple-a bangers like people make this
table city is my duals yeah I don't know
how I've flip city is just again for the
group that loves it great you know to me
it's not even really more so about I was
upset because grounding was there I was
just upset like King nailed it person
out too much personality that's it they
get rid of that go to the joint we
couldn't let me get this super chest
real quick when Larry does his unboxing
with the white gloves I love you know
y'all dudes don't like it actually love
that little segment with him it's his
stuff like when he has to interact with
people yeah I don't want faces no faces
let it be like unboxing thing with Larry
you know I just I just feel to keep it
on all cylinders yes it's a game pass
thing then just be like you know
launching owning game pass
bang bang bang bang bang that's it I
think you get a part of the effect super
chat we get out of it Victor Alateen to
lots of chat inside Xbox needs one or
two hosts for each show interesting
oh no ma'am yo GOG you gotta stop logo
he said there's three up CdSe this is
TBC yeah it is what it is that is all I
we gonna get up out of here oh yes move
we got oh I miss Morris move yes
inside Xbox because without it those
personalities would be laid off that is
true because they were small amount of
time and then they brought them back
respect the smaller titles at the start
of the journey Xbox lost indie support
Xbox is the most diverse platform you
played a weak innovation it makes me
laugh when he says oh I don't like the
animation or the grass kitchen cataract
can you take your ground into the
bathroom it's so good I'll take I eat
that front alert I just don't want that
from a city in it hey just call me
spoiled when they gave me outer world
you spoiled they gave me out of worlds
our world is amazing
Nintendo always get to pass no matter
what you Tendo gets a pass it don't
matter if there is if you're walking
with one leg in the game yeah we're
gonna do that for us switches company hi
oh this shows which is company hi we
can't we can't do don't slander right
I'm biased already I admit it but least
it's that state that's there what is it
good that they charm that's what we call
it they give you a one-eyed hobo charm
[Laughter]
but if there's no internet your bathroom
you can't do anyway moving all we gonna
get it I'm biased we're gonna get into
this poll get up out of here do I owe
people with the recent release of Final
Fantasy 7 remake receiving mostly
positive initial reviews do you think
part 1 of this remake should be eligible
for the game of the Year award category
the choices are a yes Final Fantasy 7
remake is a high-quality adaptation not
Master bee no it's only a subset of an
incomplete game or C I don't care y'all
better keep that same energy for the
other remastered please Rio P when it
goes up the grounded Gabe aka Lord chase
puzzle really back in the row always a
pleasure to have my brother on wicked if
I people find you what do you have going
on yeah you can excuse me find me at the
ground a gamer on YouTube and @j
Fonzarelli on Twitter right now I'm not
making any videos I'm too busy with work
and family life right now and gaming
life right now I got to put in my game
time look I love making these videos for
people by gaming over video facts have
to put that first you know but I do have
a lot of you know family stuff going on
I got for you you know shout-out to my
cousin who just passed away at Kovac
everybody stay safe out there
and those it's it's a serious virus when
it hit home like that it got even more
real for me and it's it's insane but
yeah shoutout to everybody out there in
the chat man it's it's good to see man
you guys have been amazing and just
getting bigger every week man like I I
seen the growth since the beginning like
you guys used to have like 15 people you
know what you say you was there Fonz you
know and then when I saw that first
hundred I was like yes they're finally
getting what they deserve you brother
I deserve even more I can't wait to see
that you guys are gonna keep growing and
I I'm just I'm lucky to be here thank
you girl
appreciate you bro you have no idea two
reasons why I always got a love for the
Fonz one he was there from the very
beginning he always told us he oh you
guys have something special to make us
believe when we had the five to ten
people in that chat you know I'm saying
and then number two he the only would
kick that we do cover that's was he
didn't grow to the chase and I love
these guys they took a pop you know it
was a battle like we had to fight addict
we had to fight the Japs the other
people like damn combat you know they
you would've won
yes I was like mom made farms made us
believe that we keep doing it bordick I
can't recommend this podcast to look
like this community is they've got some
amazing people you had some weirdos too
but they got some amazing people but
honestly III can't count on both hands
how many people out there that I really
respect and care for you guys are
definitely on that list
seriously you guys are amazing thank you
bunch it up true friends around that
much love Lord a together you got a runt
we can find people find you real quick
you can find me at twitter at you can
find me on youtube that's all I gotta go
don't worry I ran sketching later
brother
oh it's sovereign with the nice voice
reminding me of duties and sweepstakes
and things I forgot we're gonna pop even
funny what's going on there yeah shout
out to Fonz man Fonz is eiope family
from the rib from the bird always always
here for us the last minute a lot of
times they bailed us out last minute I
feel for what's going on in your family
my brother yeah definitely if there's no
stronger message than to tell everybody
to stay safe man this is not a game it's
not a game but thank you for joining us
today and of course you guys can find me
on Lord sob IOP on Twitter and yes an
Xbox Live you're bending me dammit
you're broken [ __ ] became dizzy $2.00
supers a shout out to Nick undead with
the gear box clap back at lot yo undead
has a fantastic article right now I'm
gonna salute it you can say up on North
gaming dotnet really given some
hindsight and it kinda to what King said
what King and I said was like we don't
know the whole situation and some new
information has come out in regards so
yeah things seem to be different from
you know we'll hopefully we'll have some
more people on next week well actually
going to touch on that we got a little
guest for that but yeah
salute the dizzy salute the undead check
out Lord gave him that net Lord King
with the financial status of Sony and
their dealings as always he's always
good to get their financing report from
you shout out the funds that's my god
one day he thought I was real erratic on
the show he was like King you all right
man you know what it was you were quite
and I was like man I'm going on you know
I was touch bases because I think
therefore my dog passed yes maybe yes
yeah yeah but no I'd like to check up on
friends and stuff I don't like you no no
I appreciate that that's all that's all
I love that I love the fact that you
know people can take away the rough
exterior mm-hmm and reach out and be
like yo what's up man no he's not not
too many y'all know it was me fons and
meds
bad thing and we're trying to Center it
around a really neat idea gonna put the
idea you know we are still you know in
its that mode that that stuff and still
happen because you know your family you
know from the craters it sorry
we will give something like that going
because how I wanted to set up trust me
it will definitely be a certified hit um
ok school a lot of you guys be looking
at my promo videos thinking that's the
video for the for the cable you know cog
has made me cut down those videos to 20
cut those videos down the 10-second yeah
I think we might need to go to 10 that
these dudes is boots you know here baby
move take yourself over there and go
check out that statue and go get that
statue is proper respect that's 1,400
hours of face on that that's right over
there to log net or go to the YouTube
channel and check that out or follow me
on Twitter that King David OTW you know
could be looking up Laura King Dave
you'll be following somebody else so we
throw the crest up I get to see my
brother boss moves interval the Winnie's
in itself
shut out there he said shut up the IOP
for the Final Fantasy 7 remake you all
the winners are head up solving the dams
good to see the chapter they ever seen
you in a while so I'm glad that you
actually did when I was actually pretty
dope so del salut salut so you already
heard the king you already know and of
course like I said you know please check
us out on once a gaming dinette
tremendous those articles man the kid
the boys are killing it right now lava
is killing it we got a lot of things
cooking man please check that I also our
Lord Josh Freddie has a tremendous
destiny article right now that's going
up doing some good numbers and stuff
like that but say about the last word no
I see and I'm about to say that
yeah you always go for that new thing
that you say every shots of my brother
he boxes the last word podcast the best
destiny podcast you have never heard
that's not it that is how go do tell me
how I got a joint man you said the best
damn destiny [ __ ] best damn destiny
podcast you have never heard all Fridays
you already know what it is man really
go at it and it's fun and please you
gotta check it out when it goes up or
ILP later on that Friday as well man
please support even if you don't like
this dude's hilarious please is there
but yes salute man I guess looking on
king of statues out here killing it
please watch the videos or hit log then
don't try to cheap out on the promo and
then browse we're not about that life
you didn't see anything in a box I'm you
write the destroyable box and did shovel
pick the air you might have to do that
because they they try to hustle right
there but look there that's all I got
everybody please enjoy your Sunday
Easter happy Easter be safe and we'll
see you guys next week peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]